[Music]
there so yeah Paul Young has introduced
for those we haven't yet met me job
title is got a market director for s CP
Google cloud history quickly is actually
for some for some reason LinkedIn has
decided to auto-generate post this week
that says congratulate Paul on spending
one year at Google cloud and so
currently my email has been bombarded by
people congratulating me so I guess I've
been a year in three days enroll at s at
Google before that twenty years of their
cp8 years of your package deploying
running their SUV infrastructure so if
you do math that means I'm old right and
it's we've come a long way in one year I
will tell you at Google so just to give
you an example really quickly of where
we are the June last year next San
Francisco we announced that we have the
12 and the 18 terabytes VMs available
and it takes an act of God to
pre-announce
anything at Google I have to tell you
and we in order to get that to work we
actually had to buy the hardware install
it and make sure it ran and would do
everything we claimed it would before we
allowed to pre-announce it and so it
wasn't a in our world it was a pretty
fixed event that we would committed to
launching these and we're going to
launch them because we already had the
hardware that said as obviously brad
announced this morning in the keynote
the 12 and the six are available right
now in early access to customers to
become fully available this half and so
politely I'll say promises made and
promises kept
and at the time I'll tell you there was
a lot of questioning on whether we were
going to do this because no one had
produced a VM bigger than 4 terabytes of
the time this question was even
technically possible and what it would
do but we've delivered it and we've
delivered on a plan here with great
intention and a plan that continues on
and one just fill in some gaps really
quickly here to explain why we've been
obsessed with the the Oh being the only
cloud provider that's doing
for one VM for our entire stack because
we believe it opens up huge potential
for how you run SCP and how you can run
that better and how you can manage to
sort of change that comes day to day
with running SCP environments you know
just to give you one quick example Brad
talked about this earlier as well in the
environment we had a customer in the
life sciences space who came to us and
said look one of our big challenges is
downtime right the law being what the
law is right now that if you're in the
pharmaceutical business you're in the
medical device business you
fundamentally can't manufacture of ACP
isn't online right you're required to
record for pharmaceuticals the
ingredients that were used the recipe
that was used and if it's not online you
can't record that if you're building
pacemakers and you have to record the
battery and who it came from a Bachelor
came from so that in the event of a
fault wien traced everybody who has a
pacemaker with that batch of batteries
installed in it
and so literally if STP isn't running
then they have to shut down the entire
company until it comes back up again so
the CIO basically said look we're a 10
billion dollar a year manufacturer in
the life sciences space and every hour
we're ACPs down it costs us a million
dollars the answer was you know if you
can do something about that then that's
something better right and again coming
back to why we VN based why do we care
about VMs we're VMI's to be careful that
much because when things we have is live
migration right so what happens is
basically if we detect a patch needs to
be put in for security purposes instead
of us what everybody else on the planet
does we just send you an email saying
you have 72 hours to shut down your
systems and take a three hour outage for
you patch your environment which is you
know three million dollars in lost
revenue you weren't planning for what
happens in our world is a brand-new VM
pops up at exactly the same size and
shape of what you're running it's pre
patch for security and then we replicate
the the system across while it runs the
memory the CPU state the disk and when
we achieve sync your original drops out
and you continue onwards and $3,000,000
saved every time we do that for one
customer right and up until now nobody
can do that right now only we can do
that only we can do it for anything over
half a terabyte we're going all the way
up to 12
that grass at 18 right the bigger you
get the bigger the number is and so
that's I think the bit you first want to
understand about where we're at in
Google cloud right is we didn't enter
this market saying I kind of Lee when I
came on board the conversation was hey
if we just want to be a hosting provider
for SCP then let's just go buy a hosting
company right we don't want to be a
hosting provider we want to be the best
run environment for SCP and that's the
first step of it I'll give you a
separate example of where we're at one
of the things again whatever else has to
do right now is you have to take a
three-year commit to an SCP server so
you come through and you say you know
hey I am I plan for SVP from the
beginning of time
what STP says is where you need to go to
a quick sizer and I need to tell me how
what your busiest hour is going to be
three years from now and and we're gonna
buy all of that equipment and we're
gonna run it and and hopefully you've
sized it correctly but you're gonna run
all that equipment hoping you get your
growth retry hoping you get your
customer demand right and everything
else to where you need to be in three
years so I've done this conversation a
lot with the retailer's I my first
question generally I say in the retail
pharmacies is does anyone know and
there's a risk here because I think
there is someone in the audience who
knows this so don't answer it you but
does anyone know what the best selling
toy was three years ago
so Christmas 2015 anyone know what the
number one selling toy was no no I've
done this a lot generally people don't
know you can check me on this but I
believe the number one selling toy
Christmas 2015 was an Elsa doll and the
fact that none of us have remembered
that is indicative of how little we know
about history never mind the future
right if anyone can tell me what the
top-selling toy is in 2022 then we're
both in the wrong business right and
given that you can't do that the concept
that you know how big your se B system
needs to be three years from now and you
can contact with me for that capacity is
ludicrous right but it's what everybody
else does
except us because we're a virtual
machine-based
so what you don't buy for me is fixed
machines where you buy from me is
capacity right and if you need more than
that capacity two years from now it's
okay you can just
increase the capacity that you need
right likewise where you look out here
as a command where we're beastly - I am
15 terabytes of memory and committing it
in Frankfurt
let's see you need 12 terabytes but you
know you are bytes now right right now
you've got a bunch of little dev box is
never else so what you need right now is
24 5 terabytes great let's say tomorrow
you need 6 1 terabytes and 3 2 terabytes
great let's say the day after you need
112 to our bite great you just
restructure as you need to no one's done
that flexibility before right so there's
my very quick State of the Union on
where we are we made a lot of promises
last year to customers where we said
we're going to be different we're gonna
have the best run environments politely
we've delivered
we're delivered on time and and then
secondarily politely we've only just
started there's a lot more to come but
with that I've always said in this space
that and that SUV customers don't
actually buy from salespeople it has to
be customers buy from SCB customers
generally it's a very small but very
active tribe where when one does one and
it's successful everybody else will will
learn about it and will follow so
objective for the year was was first of
all land customers per secondary and
politely land customers of significance
right so land the biggest customers we
can handle because the challenge is you
you you start small and the average has
to be customer will come along and say
well yeah they're in my industry and
yeah they're in my country but I'm
bigger than them can you really work
there's always going to be skepticism so
the answer was who are the biggest
customers in our dream sure the biggest
customers we possibly land that would
prove to this business that we're
serious we're here we do the enterprise
and we can do SCP at the larger scale
possible and and one of my dream
customers on that list was McKesson and
through good luck and good fortune
McKesson is a is a customer for STP for
Google cloud at this point so thank you
for the business but once again I could
tell you about this all afternoon it
doesn't really matter
far more important and far batteries for
you to hear from a customer themselves
so I'd like to welcome on stage
Meena Kishen Chandani and and ease it
knee from McKesson technology
there was almost perfect pronunciation
of my last night I'd be dread trading
that one all day
round the back rehearsing further you
can you can correct me for you're coming
back tomorrow for another event so no
that was almost perfect
I get points for that one apparently
well thanks so both of you a thanks for
giving us the time thanks your business
is always generally these things the
tendency is to want to talk about
technology right and we're a technology
conference frankly in this space I
believe this is as much about people as
about technology so let's let's make
this a little more personal do you want
to give the audience a little background
on your career path so far we'll get you
to your current rule at McKesson who are
you I start I'll start so I'm Andy's
that name's CTO for McKesson background
a lot of financial industry including
PayPal I see a faith contingent so a lot
of a lot of stuff learned from all of
those episodes with PayPal JP Morgan
Allstate I think Allstate was I don't
know a 70 year old company and I thought
that wasn't old enough so left there and
joined
180 year old company in the healthcare
industry and always sort of ran toward
the fire and I think in the healthcare
industry a lot of the change going on
not only with the industry itself but
also transformation in the technology
side within that industry gave me a
burning burning platform to run toward
and I decided to go see what I could do
so mean occasion Chandani
and I have been with McKesson for coming
up on almost 12 years and before
McKesson I was with the utility company
in the Midwest for a few years so I
joined McKesson as a data database
architect having no background in s AP
and joined an SI p technology team so
very quickly I kind of learned that you
know I need to you know cross over at
some point because otherwise I'm just
not gonna make it
double digits in the company so so I did
that and for a few years I did more of a
technical delivery hands-on support all
of that for the ICP applications that we
have at McKesson in a few years I kind
of started leading the team and on my
journey at McKesson then I've taken on
also some data analytics
responsibilities and then most recently
I've kind of been asked to I've been
tasked with leading some of our ERP
technology transformation work stream at
McKesson so that's my current role right
now and focused on that ERP overall ERP
transformation as well as our cloud
journey for those applications as well
cool so I start the baseline for the
people in the audience who don't know
McKesson let's just hit the background
on what is McKesson so if you take a
look at McKesson being I mentioned one
hundred and eighty year old plus company
it basically is centered around Pharma
distribution about 80,000 employees and
14 countries or so depends on the time
and and how many acquisitions were going
through how will I answer that question
also it's about 210 billion in revenue
so when you're looking at fortune list
work somewhere in that top five or six
list and if you think about from a
distribution perspective we handle one
out of every three medical units of
distribution for in the United States so
anything in the hospital whether it's a
drug or med surg device we've touched it
one out of every three and we're having
a technical problem okay when
double-fisted on the slight controller
there you go don't work okay can we go
back to you hit the button one more
perfect miss anything
over 275,000 skews the size up on a
slide so this is really who we are so
when you think about from an SI p
perspective
the landscape you're looking about
twenty two data centers globally we may
not be the largest sa P implementation
but the what's out there and everybody
keeps talking about is we're one of the
highest transaction processing si P
environments in the world but it's Mina
will go into a lot more of this it's a
very complex environment because we've
grown through acquisition so it's not a
single instance or anything nice and
clean like that it's a bunch of them
sort of taped together I always think I
mean I'm by visiting McKesson a few
times with my a CV badge on before I
came visiting with my Google by John I
mean the thing that always struck me is
Anna we'll come back to this in Mia's
conversation but but yeah if you guys
catch a cold
the world has a problem basically I mean
fundamentally when we straight into this
it's funny Google they said well what do
we need to know about McKesson then my
answer is look the you know imagine your
local hospital and you know understand
all the supplies all the pharmaceuticals
all the bandages all the saline bags
everything for quiet everyday and then
realize they don't have warehouses
attached to them which they shoot right
well they don't because these guys are
the warehouse literally the the you know
you place an order for any medical
product and forty hours later it will be
delivered anywhere in America or
throughout Europe I mean literally if
something goes wrong the world of
healthcare has a problem it's just
amazing what you do and the skill you do
it at you're a critical part of the
economy ultimately it's critical
infrastructure for the healthcare
industry right and everything that we
push down our distribution centers are
cleared out within a couple of hours so
it's really like having to distribution
centers online 24 by 7 around the
country yeah so with that I mean
healthcare so fascinating industry to be
in but it's an industry that's changing
really quickly right fascinating that's
a good word for it it is a fascinating
industry to be in right now because
everything's changing it's not unlike
any other industry but I think it's it's
getting it from multiple fronts you're
having the disruptions from your nine
I'll say your non legacy players
everybody thinks of Amazon and others
entering in the space thinking that its
regulatory and it was protected that
isn't such the case anymore there's a
lot of entries coming
and then when you take a look at the
government getting involved with the
healthcare industry and especially when
you think about running in the EU or the
UK region and some of the government
involvement there and how they influence
everything in healthcare and then just
pile on top of there this shift from
what I'll say is the legacy healthcare
experience that we have today moving
toward away from generic drugs and
moving more toward specialty drugs that
are really a drug manufacturer
particularly for you I'm your DNA and
trying to get that from the manufacturer
basically into your body as fast as
possible that's a whole different
distribution problem that well we solved
for with the generics distribution so
change comes every day and so with that
I think when the interesting zandi's I
know you've been on the conference tour
a lot recently so once again thanks your
time here but I know a year ago and the
conversations I was having with SCB
customers and cloud customers in general
the theme was always lift and shift and
lifted shift and I'll tell you so far
this year there's been very little
conversation about lifting shift there's
this understanding at this point that
running it here - running it there there
may be some economies but ultimately
it's about the ability to handle change
it's about the next generation
architecture right I know you have
strong feelings about this so how do you
feel yeah this was really where sort of
the architecture conversation came in
and really where we got Google brought
to the table in the dialogue and and the
conversation for me was how do we solve
the ERP right for sa P for us everything
else is going to follow so whatever we
do with that sort of sitting in the
center about 90% of our universe is
going to follow that application suite
however we architect that solution
what this is is really the target
architecture basically what we said was
and my team takes offense to this but
below the value line above the value
line right we want to operate and
deliver as much of that below the value
lines so that's value to the customer
and just have that delivered pick a
partner pick a partner that has the
culture that you want to fit your your
target culture for your organization and
your company
bring them to the table they have the
right solutions you heard about the
jumbo VMs right that was a major
separation for us when we were looking
for the partners because we knew we had
to solve for that large si P environment
it just wasn't a net new build fresh
type of environment you had to solve for
the purchase packages so what we looked
at was really plowing everything into
partners below the line bring the right
strategy and and strategic partners to
that below line and then allow our
employees to operate above line right so
if you're thinking like gee CPA Sutton
ss4 on GCP that gives us an environment
that we can then release some of our
internal employees to be software
engineers above mine to do things like
data analytics on top of that platform
and that's our whole strategy so as
opposed to for the last five years I
think a lot of companies were just
taking everything and saying hey let's
run it in the cloud and we'll do the
lift and shift so they ran it and and
they ran it the same way it was the same
application wasn't refactored and it was
sitting on really expensive
infrastructure as a service
architectures that's not at all what we
want to do we want to refactor the
applications and put in an architecture
that allows us to add value above that
line to the customer and not pay much
attention to what's below cool and
million slash billion dollar question in
this case cuz I'm sure there's a bunch
of people sit in this audience and
Beyond watching the replay as well whose
answer is okay that sounds like a great
vision I want to get there and I want to
get there isn't necessarily just sign
the contract with GCP it's also you're
persuading the executives here and the
company to want to buy by end of that
vision - how do you I mean you and me
met to start this process last June at
lunch at next right in the nine months
since just give us a highlight of what
you had to go through to get to where we
are now know it's a bit of a perfect
storm - si P there our current
environment when does it end like 2025
2025 and a life we also have to Edwards
in the environment it's coming out of
life - so we have a perfect storm and
around
what we're going to be touching so the
real selling point was we want to do
this a lot different so if we move
toward this target architecture you're
going to be touching about 80% of your
plant from application sweet perspective
you're going to be touching it anyway so
let's do this significantly different
the selling point of the y at that point
become became a conversation around
enabling speed the value for the
business because what they feel today is
a very methodical I'll say like
enterprise release release type of
planning where when they think of the
product or the enhancement it's six nine
twelve months before they can actually
see it in the environment we go to this
architecture and there's a lot more to
this architectural engines GCP right the
API architecture and everything else
that enables it to move with speed but
once you have that in place they can
think about the enhancement and start
putting it in within weeks hopefully
within days and this is probably the
scope of what we're doing with McKesson
isn't limited to SCP right no it's it's
it's very holistic right it's an entire
ecosystem
Sarika system is a it's a big EU system
speaking of which Mina I know again when
I spent my time with my SUV by John I'm
a guess and it's a high-priority
customer there's very few bigger and
very few more critical but you want to
just give the audience an understanding
of the sort of scope we're talking about
sure I wish our actually ecosystem
looked as clean and neat as it looks on
the slide to be honest but it is a
pretty fairly large ecosystem and we
have you know more than 25 plus products
deployed already across multiple
countries including 13 countries in
Europe and US and Canada and we have an
Esso s4 implementation going on in UK as
well for which we'll be deploying I
think six or even more products there so
when it comes to the number of
environments we are we have almost 60
plus landscapes I could not get a
definite number because it's
ever-changing as anybody who works with
us if he knows especially the
team and then 260 plus instances so it
is n plus 1 minute for many landscapes
that's an N plus 1
landscape as well and just in North
America one of our ECC systems that
services are pharmaceutical distribution
business unit it's it's 100 plus
terabytes it's you know so that's if you
think about the number of systems that
are copies of production in the
landscape you're touching almost you
know just for that one landscape it's
close to at least I would say half a
petabyte and on top of that you add
secondary storage where we have a very
proactively archived data business data
so that's pretty huge as well and then
you add the multiple copies of backups
and other kind of archives and all of
that it's a pretty large footprint
storage footprint just for that one
instance yeah so and then that
particular instance also is a very high
volume transaction processing system
upwards of close to up to two million
line items a day so so you can imagine
the complexity involved to support that
large of an environment as well we are
also a pretty mature HANA shop I would
say we've we have multiple HANA
deployments as well we have a 24
terabyte bwn HANA environment we have a
6 terabyte Sweden HANA with Padova
sticks add-on environment and a 4
terabyte be PC on Hanah environment and
that's just naming some of them out
there so yeah so we have a large talent
pool that understands Hana pretty well
and so is kind of getting ramped up for
the next generation of our ERP currently
we as I mentioned I think we have this
are UK as for implementation in in
flight and and it is actually started on
GCP and with all of that I think we
safely say we are amongst the top five
you know I'm not it chain I guess III
think it's up on that scale of one to
five but I think I'm to be safe I'll say
it's it's top I think you're safely in
top five yeah that's why I love you
because the you know the everyday we
deal with the question of yeah but who
do you have this bigger the mean and
generally the answer we McKesson the
soprano GCP gently ends that
conversation and there's not many people
bigger than McKesson I think the other
point just really quickly was this two
million lines a day hate something the
thing that was certainly fascinating
being terrified me about McKesson is
it's a granular business I mean that
order doesn't say just go to the
warehouse and grab a bottle of
pharmaceuticals and ship it it tells you
the specific bottle of pharmaceuticals
socialize there's a huge amount of
compute power involved in making those
decisions and and and making healthcare
traceable and correct right yeah exactly
and these me uh these line items I mean
the it's actually bulk of it is
processed in a four to six peak hour
window so when you talk about compute I
mean you really have to design for that
peak peak workload and and if you think
about the you know especially in in
products in our specialty and for a
plasma and biologic space you think
about the the absolute endpoint customer
sitting there waiting for the product I
mean you can imagine what kind of
availability requirement we have and
also what kind of performance in
throughput requirement we have here and
this is just one environment so it's
like so yes so it is pretty complex I
would say yeah so given that scope
clearly the answer isn't hey let's just
run a migration tool and get it all over
there by next Tuesday right you you've
got a structure to this down so the card
in front of me says what's the plan to
eat the elephant basically but I mean
how do you how do you plan to break this
down how do you plan to kind of
structure this across so I think I think
starting with a net new implementation
that's that's going on in UK is the
perfect start where we learn from that
process because and we are started or
starting it directly on the cloud itself
and some of our enterprise principals
around you know keeping the ERP core
clean and taking not actually not
building customizations in there in the
ERP platform itself and taking them
building them as side by side extensions
using GCP services and using some other
technologies called modern technologies
I think that's where that's going to
help us actually plan our North America
kind of journey and because lifting and
shifting of our current environment I
don't think we can even move this one
landscape that I talked about to
actually a DCP itself so so that's the
plan that we learn from there and then
we take those learnings bring them back
and incorporate them as part of our
North America ERP transformation journey
yeah
so you and me were in Stuttgart along
with a bunch of other Google and
McKesson people early March the first
week of March be a better memory than I
do
currently on dates so yeah right about
four or five weeks ago to get this all
storied what have you learned so far a
lot yes we cuz we did a set of work with
you before in terms of testing
reliability and failover and ER so it
starts before it's to verify we yeah
yeah so I think our journey actually
started with you guys
late October November last year and the
the perfect I mean it was at the time
the implementation in Europe that I'm
talking about they had to make some
decisions around procuring hardware for
that implementation and also we had this
evaluation going on for a primary cloud
partner so it was the perfect
opportunity to bring back use case in
and actually kickoff a POC of sorts and
I think that POC was about a four to six
week POC where we everything from soup
to nuts we stood we we kind of were able
to stand up and s4 environment at that
point we didn't even have any network
connectivity with McKesson data centers
so from networking point onwards I think
to an
then there was about I want to say about
15 to 20 technical operational criterias
that we had put put down and they were
pretty extensive things like backups
restores system copies moving you know
scaling on-the-fly live migration and
there's a bunch of others that we
actually you know made that in those as
our success criterias and from that
point onwards you know based on the
successful outcome of that particular
PRC we've then made those decisions that
you know the our UK SOP implementation
will start on GCP and then we have had a
workshop to enable the platform enough
to get this implementation started and
then early March is where the first week
of March we had a hackathon over there
where prior to the hackathon we did a
training for the teams there so that
they could come in and actually be
productive as in actively participate
and build things there with the teams I
think your team was there and then the
PSO and the Tam so there was a pretty
wide representation from Google over
there and so but then three days we were
able to stand up I think for asipi
systems we did also spend time on
building some automation there and not
just manually kind of you know deploying
so so achieving all of that in three
days I think it's it's been phenomenal
and since then you know those teams have
been enabled enough to continue that
that the those deployments on their own
I think yeah Andy Andy and me talked the
week after Andy's assertion was I think
these exact words cool more than this
work I don't know what cool heed you
gave them but they certainly drank it so
I'll take that response from a customer
anything well like I said this was the
big hurdle talking internally McKesson
was getting the PSAP what I'll say is
the the heritage or legacy s AP
contingent sold off or bought off on
that we could actually do this right
because that wasn't an easy conversation
we started it and internally a couple of
years ago I think this is one of the
challenges right when you may the SCP
talent at this point is hard to find a
lot of it is retiring off there's huge
demand for it as we go through this or
on upgrades so part of the plan here has
to be to kind of keep people engaged so
I asked one of the questions we get a
lot here which is you know people don't
always react well to change and this is
change and so can you make it change in
a way that it actually engage these
people and carries it through so it mean
coming back to the hackathon and that
sort of stuff Mina do you think what can
we do to keep people engaged and make
this a project they want to work on I
think it's just about you know the art
of the possible showing them that vision
as to what's really possible because
they are even talent in the SCP space is
also looking to really expand and become
more cloud aware and also kind of think
of new solutions that you can augment
and bring in to the ASAP environment
itself so so to be able to set the more
we can enable them the more we can help
them show the vision I think that would
be actually really that's the path to
success it's fast exact a conversation
at lunch with another customer as well
and it's something you'd raised up to me
before which is I think part of the
challenge is is people tend to benchmark
what they do right now against what
they'll do in the future and part of the
conversation is how can you get them to
a point of you know what's possible now
and then how they can go from there and
it's that moving people was kind of
mindset to know instead of where they
were I think that's where things that
learn things that fascinated me I'd say
about this trigger is you know we
started showing some things very quickly
the McKesson people elbowed us over the
week as they went to do it himself and
he went to own it and take it over it
was fascinating me how quickly that
happened in the room and yeah I mean all
credit to you both of you in the Hossein
team for the enthusiasm and the
excitement I see him I guess yeah does
that fair and comes of that I mean I
think I think you guys delivering the
engineers to the room right and getting
the engineers sitting together and
talking nothing against all the sales
team that's here but getting the
engineers in the room and working
together they got excited themselves and
one
you can see them start to think on the
whiteboards and start walking through
this that became the art of the possible
and then later on there a lot of the
automation conversations they came in
play right I think that was a big
differentiator when we when we were
taking a look at the partner right
Google comes in with a software
engineering mindset first and not a lot
of the others out there do yeah very
cool
so one of my favorite questions to that
is least favorite question two three
five years from now how do we measure
success how do we know we've been
successful you can say me I think every
year that success criteria is gonna
change so I'm only thinking one year at
a time at this time so for me there's
over the next year you know its
quantitative qualitative so if we can
get our si P Europe instrumentation s
for implementation you know the
production deployed and working and
where there's great user experience both
from IT and our business users I think
that's a huge that's a number one in my
in my opinion because that is our
opportunity to really sell you know
basically convince everybody else that
this is gonna work I think the other
thing is if we can drastically reduce
our reliance on our external partner
partners including Google where our
people can do things on their own
because they're really kind of ramped up
I think that's another one for me and I
think finally the third one is for North
America if we can move the dial forward
and get some of our sa p cloud ready
type environments successfully migrated
I think for me that's like I'm just
looking one year at a time because I
don't even want to think about beyond
that I'll start with where I started
last night that I didn't get fired
because
so that's that's where the bar sets and
then we go above that and say you know a
couple things I think the the customer
experience has to change right this
can't just be the exact same environment
so it has to be an environment that
enables us to change the business
process enable business process change
in a simplistic manner and at pace and
get the business to the table thinking
is a lot different than what we do today
and leveraging this environment and the
capabilities within the environment that
gives a the business opportunity to
think differently on enhancements as
opposed to I go back to that or the
comment I made earlier when we start
thinking about an enhancement or a
change or a customization that's a long
process today in their current
environment it'll be nice when they're
sitting at the table and it's an easy
conversation so you know I would really
like to just change this and do that in
a different manner
can we look at that and we give them an
environment where yeah we can you know
tell me that on a Monday and we can do
it on a Friday and they say yeah that's
exactly what I want then we go live but
production right so it's enabling the
business to think much differently than
what they do today in a huge environment
any much hopefully much more simplistic
environment when we implement it and
then the last thing I'd say is you know
Nina mentioned keep the core whole for
us that really means all customizations
well a lot of the customizations 90
percent of the customizations are done
on our custom platform and not built
into the core purchased application that
gives us massive change in the
architecture that'll give us
upgradability sustainability of the core
and much less cost to maintain and
enable the business enhancements at our
pace with our resources I think it's
interesting actually the the this change
thing has started to come up with
customers who've been with us for a
while because again in that VM based
world historically one of the dings
against SCP is you can't change right
and that or not that you can't change
but it but that you have an idea but
it's got to fit into the change control
mechanism and so you were to justify and
it takes a while and you
to have to scale them up and that
ability to do small incremental change
that would make a huge difference just
isn't there in the platform and bulaga
is driven by hardware constraint right
and we've seen this a couple customers
have said look I think just copy off a
QA system I can try out my concept if I
like it it's good I could have proved it
I can roll it in and that ability to
kind of unlock the the capacity of the
organization to change in innovates
fascinating right it opens up a
potential and SCP that's not there the
other thing I'd just add in really
quickly is when you're above the line
below the line discussion for some of
the customers that are little been with
us a while there's one in particular
where at GCC I own a show recently where
I said yeah I just want to check in that
everything's going okay right because I
haven't heard from you and his answer
was look I've had I've been wife for
nine months and I've had zero incidents
where we've had to call Google Cloud he
says it's only one I was fantastic on
the other hand you know I see a lot of
my other salespeople because you know
their system breaks and I ever I call
them and share with them and then we
talk about other stuff right it's like I
never have to call you to show you so we
never talk and nice problem to have
however it's fascinating because it's
where things I think long term we're
gonna have to chase through as much as
like the hackathon ever there's really
good where we're having to invest to get
you people to speed I think ultimately
the conversation I've had with a bunch
of other CIOs is ultimately they want us
to effectively be invisible right they
want us to be a utility that's just
there and works and there's ultimate
team that happens and so I think we're
so finding our way in terms of how do
you engage with the customer contribute
you know make them success or but
equally know when to when to back off
and then leave them you know with us in
the utility space does that make sense
in you're above the line below the line
yeah and you know it's the whole dynamic
above and below that value line is the
bullet that line was flat in that
drawing it's definitely not flat right
froze so it goes across a bunch of
business capabilities and depending on
the business capability is depending on
where you want to draw that line in my
mind right because you could draw that
line very low and say there is a lot
above that line that adds a value and
it's a differentiator and they're in the
in the business so let's have more money
invested above that line there's others
that four core services and I think s AP
course
Services is one of those there's a lot
below that line as a ton below that line
and we would like to get that as a to
your your point as a commodity and just
deliver it to the business then let them
think of things like pricing engines and
everything else above that line and put
all their focus up there as opposed to
us talking to them about we have an
upgrade coming we have a patch coming
we're gonna have an outage fired and
everything else they shouldn't have
those conversations anyway yeah for
example to upgrade today in one of the
largest environment that I'm talking I
talked about it takes anywhere between
twelve nine to twelve to eighteen months
and a millions and millions of dollars
of investment because of how complex it
is and and all of the stuff that we've
built on top of it over the years like I
said earlier stay tuned whether you're
aware we've got some other stuff we're
not done innovating yet that answer of
that I shall say no more before PR bugs
me for both of you I would say I'd say
we're a year or more effectively nine
months on what do you know now that you
wish you knew nine months ago when you
were starting this process so I think
I'm not sure about the nine months but
it's it's I probably go back to the
experience we've at least I've had or my
team has had on working with with cloud
on some even prior to those nine months
so our journey I I'm sure at McKesson
has been on for some years and some of
the AAP folks have been also trying to
build some capabilities for at least a
couple of years so I'll go back to that
reference point and not the nine months
reference point so it has to be
obviously it's an you know no brain
brainer that you have to kind of invest
in your people because traditional ways
of thinking sometimes takes times time
to change then if you have to really
kind of ramp up quickly to get some
change going I think
you have to partner with you know the
external expertise and experience as
well while your staff is coming up talk
to customers who've done this before and
then from a process perspective I'd say
really invest in automation assess what
your team is spending their most time on
on doing manual tasks those are
candidates for automation from day one
so so definitely that should be your
focus as you're thinking about moving to
cloud the other thing that comes to mind
is a challenge this 24 by 7 assumptions
for some of your non production
environments because you know it is it's
not as it helps for period and I think
there's also something for the speed at
the end of the day because it does clean
up your environment you don't have to
worry about all the integration points
that you have today yeah there's so much
it's fascinating because again if you
define it as lift and shift it's easy
it's just the stuff that stairs over
there just sponge bob mean basically
right the point where you realize that
you can get additional value from it
it's it's a lot more thinking right yeah
and it's not a technical problem anymore
it's not just uh here's a tool and you
can move it there's a lot more it's a
it's a project right it involves
business people and changing people's
lives and everything Alice is a much
more work last question says well again
nine months ago we all a group of people
have lunch and from here that's where we
started to know where you guys started
and know we're here equally there's a
bunch of people sitting in this audience
who likely are here for the first time
having lunch and and thinking about
getting started what would you what
would you tell them other than enjoy
lunch I would say you know how do you
get started is just that go get started
I guess my quieter with a question
what's what's playing me what's your
other options right is is it like for
like and maintaining the same and I
think if that's your answer you may want
to rethink it
because the business going to look at is
more the same and slowdown and I think
you'll have a different conversation
with your business you go to them with a
strategy that is is demonstrating and
not necessarily that value line slide
but demonstrating that conversation that
you really are trying to free up the
company's resources to plow into that
the differentiating business processing
above that line and this is how we think
we can do it and articulate it I think
it's a much better conversation and
they'll be more eager to get started
Mena yeah I think III think most of what
Andy said is what you know is what I'm
thinking as well because like for like
is really there's no business case there
to be honest at least if you're like
McKesson or even close to it it's just
not gonna work so so so you have to be
open to kind of really tech ting you're
not just from a technology perspective
but also you know you're you're kind of
not quite culture I would say but but
how the messaging that goes from top
down to the people and how you energize
the base as well because that's that's I
think one of the most important things
that if they're not bought and then
that's going to be tough to achieve once
again thank you for your business thank
you for your time so certainly really do
appreciate you taking time for sharing
your wisdom with everybody
[Music]